ceausescus und herzlich willkommen zu
einem refugium worum es heute geht das
sieht ja nach dem intro
ja es gibt ein paar sachen zu erzählen
und zwar wenn ich dieses wochenende auf
so einem kleinen kongress sein so
bislang raster von unternehmertum und
ganze leben von uni seiten her und
deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr leisten jetzt jeden tag ein video
zu bringen bis wochen
ich werde mal schauen wie ich habe heute
abend noch die gelegenheit zu
produzieren muss ich mal schauen wie
weit ich da komm ich jetzt erstmal
besten trainers dass das sport machen so
muss auch machen und dann werde ich
schauen wie weit ich komme und wie viel
ich vor produzieren kann aber auf jeden
fall kann es sein dass dieses wochenende
ist also weiter gesangstag sonntag und
vor allem auch heute kein video kommen
kann weil ich wie gesagt bis vor wenigen
zeit hab ich habe jetzt gerade viel uni
stress und so es geht auf die klausuren
phase zu sehen wollte ich nur kurz
informieren was da so abgeht und euch
dann natürlich auch gleichzeitig noch
fragen was sie eigentlich in diesem
projekt haltet also vom ort was jetzt
ein bisschen angelaufen ist seit vier
folgen das glaube ich schon
die draußen sind ihr könnt ihr jetzt mal
unter dieses video eure meinung
schreiben was ihr von diesem projekt
halte weil es immer gut bei schlaf
feedback zu bekommen so wie das jetzt
natürlich auch wieder ein bock habt oder
so weil ich mache es ja auch
gewissermaßen auch für euch und ja da
schreibt einfach mal unter das video was
ihr davon haltet
ob wir weitere fortsetzungen blabla
pipapo könnte rein machen ob
irgendwelche wünsche hat irgendwelche
ergänzung was ich machen soll die
projekt und eventuell auch leute mit
denen ich aufnehmen soll weil ich zum
beispiel jetzt mal fabian geschrieben
hab also minecraft 925 wege öffnen was
du bist noch mal ein bisschen power
action machen oder so was hab ich bock
drauf wir sind ja weil er so die im
projekt dieser bisschen php action
machen und dadurch dem auch mal
hinsetzen so ein bisschen power ranger
darauf lust habt wie gesagt in die
kommentare schreiben
und ja noch eine sache was sie gar nicht
weiß wenn ihr mehr lust auf reede
live-videos habt also die ist wohl
einfach so ein bisschen aber ohne
irgendwie gm place im hintergrund da
können wir natürlich auch noch themen
raussuchen könnt ihr auch ihr können in
die kommentare schreiben wenn ihr
irgendwelche fragen habt kann ich
einfach mal so besprechen
dann könnten wir natürlich auch ich sind
mehrere live videos machen die kann ja
jetzt lange nicht mehr
also wenn ihr lust hat auf die live
videos wieder damit in die kommentare
und jetzt hat er eigentlich genug zu tun
aber nicht sagen
reimers gut und ciao